here to answer that question is body
language expert Judy James hi it's good
to see you thanks again should we just
look up to start with on the Greenpeace
thing given that I was just speaking to
the lady from Greenpeace how did she
handle that she handled it well but
she's prime minister you know everybody
was saying oh she stayed calm they
should be throwing firecrackers at her
like they do with the police horses
people shouldn't react I think she
actually became better after it I think
the Applause that she got here on the
back of it it seemed to break the ice a
bit for her so the start of the speech
she was not particularly good but she
did improve after this so I think it
actually did her a few favors although
she did say get them removed which I
wasn't sure that was that sounds a bit
like uh it was it the Red Queen off with
their heads or something like that
I use that every day I get them removed
I want to be more generally about what
her body language she did she look quite
stiff to start with and then the walk-on
is always massively important isn't it
it is
um I've never done well I mean the the
smiles that they were wearing on arrival
it looked like everybody had been kind
of you know you must smile so we've got
this Overkill Smiles going on
um the walk-on is absolutely so hard I
wouldn't Envy anyone doing that I'd
I always say jacket and pants might help
a bit with the walk-on but no why is
that it just those dresses are so
awkward anyway they're very limiting but
um she clearly likes them
um yeah I thought you're gonna have to
do a bit of fracking to find her
Charisma aren't you really I mean it
it's well hidden and this was probably
the worst bit
um as you say quite robotic the smiles
didn't look quite genuine we got a lot
she's she's selling herself as a very
strong woman
um her body language to a certain extent
is is self-heckling on that one because
she she stands like that a lot now
um it's called The upturned V under the
armpit I think I've told you about this
before the benefit of those who don't
know yeah for those at home um it's a
gap under the armpit and the shoulders
down where we feel really powerful
really confident we have that gut
unfortunately when we don't feel that
confident the arms come in the elbows
and the arms coming against the Torso in
a self-hug and that's when you get these
odd hand gestures so she did some empty
Embrace that worked quite well with the
arms out but this kind of thing and
particularly with these very anxious
spiky fingers
um she managed to look quite confident
but these will be little giveaways maybe
that that would tell me that she's not
quite as confident if she's looking
I do that though to hide my bingo wings
no Bingo wings I think
and people do that
funnily enough and this is gonna if you
are but even there you're not you're not
self-hugging if you've got it though
that's fine I mean yeah if you really
have Bingo Wings you'd have to do that
because they'd be like hold and roll but
um no she also with her
body language and the way that she was
speaking as well she's channeling
Thatcher still
um I'm wearing a High Street dress
good idea was what a High Street dress
no dress I mean I I don't get the
dresses I'm afraid I mean I I don't meet
many women in business that still
wear a dress I I as I say a nice jacket
would be good
um
all of this kind of gesticulation works
quite well we've got that in fact this
was her best bet I think she's really
good buddies with she is University
together she was getting a really good
feedback there from the other ones it
was what about the oh yeah I love that
one that was so cool you know like you
know when you do that yeah it always
looks like a bit of a threat that was
James cleverly wasn't it yeah oh well
you know what he's like he's always so
cool isn't he yeah he was certainly I
mean he carried it off well it has to be
said giving her a little bit of
confidence wasn't he yeah it was again
it was Overkill though really
um this was afterwards when she came off
yeah very very glad that we didn't get
the kiss on stage with with the husband
I wouldn't have liked that one and I
mean it was very she'd just about put
one arm around his neck absolutely fine
you don't want those big things do you
remember when those two kiss on the lips
and things like that yeah I don't really
want that this this is the invisible
gesture now this is the other one that
worries me slightly because she uses it
a lot and she used it a lot in the
conference if I'm defining a problem to
you that's absolutely fine because
that's actually showing you that I
understand the problem but she never
gets to what I would call the solution
body language which should be a little
bit of a Precision gesture at the end of
it so that implies that she knows the
problems that she's inherited but I'm
waiting patient's doing it again yeah
all the time she did it all the way
through the debates
the bricks were being moved from side to
side I mean she's really on a boat which
probably used a real break there but
um but what I want from somebody who's a
leader that knows exactly how they're
going to solve it should be at some
stage problem problem what we're gonna
and that that small subtle gesture will
imply that yes we actually do have the
solution and then it's all about the
science of sensation which is not really
what she's doing but how she makes the
audience feel and when you see somebody
that does that kind of gestic lotion you
feel that quite inspired that they do
know what they're up to even if you
don't understand it yourself and he
started the power thumb oh we got that
Not only was she channeling Thatcher
with the speaking in groups of three you
know great there's great that great deal
that she'd done about four times I mean
that that's so old that totally it
always gets Applause but then she
brought out the Tony Blair thumb of
power I mean how long have I been
moaning about that one a lot a lot it
should so it should be gone it should be
gone like she dismissed the green pieces
you know Let It Drop it's not a good
sign anymore yeah but um finally I mean
as an up sum she did well she did better
than I thought she was going to a bit of
Charisma still needs she needs to play
to her own strengths rather than trying
to be other people and then I think in
that Denise Kofi and around that time I
think we've began to see some genuine
Liz trust Charisma coming out okay great
to talk to you thank you and it's always
good to have you in thank you for
joining us thank you